nearly half of the nation's wealthiest
billionaires majored in one of three
subjects in college and despite the fast
growth of tech fortunes computer science
isn't one of them those three majors
business economics and engineering in
that order altogether nearly half of the
forbes 400 members earned bachelor's
degrees in just those three fields of
study
one of those business students was mark
cuban who says he took mba classes as a
freshman at indiana university until
school officials pushed him back to
undergrad when they realized he was 18
and had never applied to be there he
eventually graduated with a general
business degree
in all 65 members of the 2021 forbes 400
majored in business while 58 members
majored in economics and 55 members
studied engineering we don't have data
on everyone's major or educational
background but we came close verifying
the information of 357 people
square co-founder jim mckelvey initially
chose economics because his father then
the dean of the engineering school at
washington university in st louis told
him engineers spend a lot of time in
labs and that he might find it too
solitary but economics wasn't enough for
the super ambitious mckelvey who was
also drawn to the engineering school in
fact he earned his second bachelor's
degree in computer science which ranks
as the sixth most popular major and was
the choice of 17 of the 400 richest
americans and while business economics
and engineering were the most popular
for these undergraduates a respectable
number majored in other subjects
politics and government and mathematics
rounded out the top six majors with 22
and 18 members respectively of course a
bachelor's degree isn't a requirement
for admission to the forbes 400 19 list
members never attended college and
another 37 dropped out before graduation
often to jumpstart their entrepreneurial
journeys including four of the top 20
richest facebook's mark zuckerberg
microsoft co-founder bill gates oracle's
larry ellison and michael dell chairman
and ceo of dell technologies
[Music]
you